but you know what it's
okay I'm totally fine everything is
going to be totally
sorry um are you free for dinner
tonight yes all right then it's a
date I'm sorry what was the
question I missed you I missed you
too lots of people think that Stanley
Hudson's Amino
Grump but would a grump make
this it's
me it's
me they loves those
pants I'll take him please after the
turtle I am enormous ly proud of what I
did for that
Turtle who did this to you where is
he
what no it's not it's
nothing it's hot
here
yeah
thanks you don't need to stay here I
know
see your PMSing pretty bad
huh if you like her so much
she don't give
up she's engaged BFD engaged ain't
married huh never ever
ever give up this is where I fell in
love with
you and this is where I ask you to marry
me it started with
[Laughter]
the
hly
flx marrying me will you
be your wife be coming me will
I what's this what is
this I don't know it's on your desk
but who put it here and for what purpose
there when I sat
down Happy Valentine's
Day it's
me I'm the
bobblehead
yes I have a friend who's single oh
Sandy she's gorgeous and she's got a
feisty personality too H feisty so she's
not Jolly or sassy not like a jolly
sassy opera singer no she's a
professional softball player
oo catcher or infield I don't know
Michael is she a dress wearer or a pants
wearer could we share a robo could could
a robo support her what do you asking I
think I'm being very clear what I'm
asking would an average size Robo
support her without
capsizing it bothers me that you're not
answering the question no all right no
she can't fit in a robot I knew it I
knew it Phyllis okay how's the family
good good are they good
yeah what's your daughter's name again
pee peepa peepa how is she great great
brownies is it h pastry cubes made of
sugar and fat no thank you I'll stick
with my jerky so why'd you come in here
to socialize and inform Michael Dwight
and I were talking about this and we
both don't understand how you didn't
realize Toby was back I'm concerned you
may have brain damage you cannot expect
me to keep track of all of my personnel
there are a lot of people here and a lot
of different shapes and sizes and there
is nothing nothing that is even vaguely
interesting about the way that he looks
so I'm off the hook maybe you cleaned
your ears too vigorously with Q I know
where this is going I am not going to
stop putting qtips in my ears I don't
care how much it
hurts you know what I'd also like to
take this opportunity to thank all of
you for lying to my face and not telling
me what's been going on this entire time
you are welcome i' like to imagine a
place that you feel very peaceful okay
for me it's the walk from the yogurt
shop to my car after I dropped my
daughter off on Sunday
afternoons I I'm glad Michael's getting
help he has a lot of issues and he's
stupid I don't think you ever cared
about me I never cared about you 6
months ago Karen filipelli sent me an
email asked me out I said no because I
was committed to our relationship well I
hope you're still committed because I'm
pregnant ever since I was a kid people
have been telling me that I can't do
things you can't be on the team you
can't move on to second grade well now
they're telling me that I can't win back
clients using oldfashioned business
methods we'll see about
that and FYI I eventually ate second
grade and I was the biggest kid in
class best dad ever give me a break give
me a break break me off a piece of
that
I am totally blanking what is the thing
nobody tell them what no why you got it
you're so close break me off a piece of
that applesauce break me off a piece of
that applesauce I don't think piece of
that Chrysler car nope football cream
okay it's football cream it's football
cream all right first name is blank and
he goes on a cruise he goes on a
Caribbean cruise I don't know k
no but he's married to her oh do Greek
no no it has to be a real person Jim
come on okay no no I'm going to pass I'm
G to pass uh okay um rhymes with
parnal rhyming really a rhyme another
clue another clue okay he is the
governor of California he is The
Terminator those aren't helpful Tom Cruz
no time God Does anybody read the
paper what I really want honestly
Michael is for you to know it so that
you can communicate it to the people
here to your clients to whomever okay
what it's whoever not whomever it's
whomever no whomever is never actually
right well sometimes it's right Michael
is right it's a madeup word used to
trick students no actually whomever is
the formal version of the word obviously
it's a real word but I don't know when
to use it correctly not a native speaker
I know what's right but I'm not going to
say because you're all jerks who didn't
come see my band last night do you
really know which one is correct I don't
know it's whom when it's the object of
the sentence and who when is the subject
that sounds right well sounds right but
is it how did Ryan use it as an object
as an object Ryan used me as an object
is he right about the how did he use it
again it was Ryan wanted Michael the
subject to uh explain the computer
system the object to whomever meaning us
the indirect object which is the the
correct usage of the word no one uh ask
you anything ever so whomever's name is
Toby why don't you take a letter opener
and stick it into your skull so Phil
recruited me to sell these cards and now
I am recruiting you who is this guy
again don't worry about Phil he drives a
Corvette he is doing just fine okay
calling cards are the wave of the Future
these things sell themselves who uses
calling cards anyway you know what
that's a nice attitude Ryan I'm just
helping you invest in your future my
friend it sounds like a getrich quick
scheme yes thank you you will get rich
quick we all will didn't you lose a lot
of money on that other investment the
one from the email you know what Toby
when the son of the king of Nigeria
emails you directly asking for help you
help his father ran the freaking country
okay all right so raise your hand if you
want to get rich all right no um how is
this not a pyramid scheme all right let
me explain
again Phil has recruited me and another
guy now we are getting three people each
the more people that get involved the
more people who are investing the more
money we're all going to make it's not a
pyramid scheme it is a it's not even a
scheme per se
it's I have to go make a
call